this video is sponsored by the team
behind marvel puzzle quest stick around
at the end of the video to learn more
about the game
hey wisecrack jared here with the
imminent release of the avengers
infinity war we thought we'd go back and
take a look at the civil war
not that one this one
now on its face civil war is a two-hour
spectacle of biceps chase's mandatory
character introductions to feed the mcu
and man you know he lifts but in
addition to some good old-fashioned
fisticuffs
civil war also explores the idea of
global fisticuffs or
international relations as you may know
it which brings us to the question
what do superpowers like the united
states have to learn from tony stark
or steve rogers welcome to this
wisecrack edition on the philosophy of
captain america civil war
don't forget to subscribe if you haven't
already and as always spoilers ahead
while the civil war comic series deals
with issues like privacy and domestic
policing in the wake of the patriot act
the film makes an ambitious break with
its source material
instead it focuses on a conflict between
two approaches to international
relations
civil war frames the conflict between
captain america and iron man as a battle
between
two opposing views on the avengers role
in the world specifically the film asks
should a us-based high-powered and
potentially destructive team like the
avengers
be allowed to operate internationally
independent of government oversight
it's a poignant question to ask
especially in the wake of america's own
questioning of its interventionism
abroad
in civil war this question comes to a
head in the debate over the sokovia
accords
the accords claim the avengers have no
right to cross national borders and
fight their highly destructive
battles without the approval of all
governments concerned their argument is
grounded in the notion of westphalian
sovereignty
the idea that a nation-state is and
ought to be in charge of all affairs
within its borders
this modern notion of sovereignty only
came to exist in 1648 after the major
european powers were tired of fighting
either the 30 years war
or 80 years war which unlike the liar
seven years war
actually lasted for as long as
advertised the resulting piece of
westphalia created the idea of
sovereignty that we understand today
but in our highly globalized modern
world things are a little more
complicated than when people were still
charging into battle on horseback many
contemporary political commentators are
all about the idea of a post-westphalian
world order
they argue that globalization has broken
down traditional ideas of who holds
power where
under this system independent actors
such as private corporations and
terrorist cells are able to wield
as much or sometimes more power than the
nation states whose borders they cross
at will
in the film the avengers are portrayed
as a product of this
post-westphalian world they are a group
of us-based superhumans who go wherever
they want
whenever they want without the
permission of local governments the film
even emphasizes this modern notion of
the avengers in its opening where our
heroes try to catch a former hydra agent
while using the language of a police
operation
complete with surveillance drones and
calls for backup sam
we need fire and rescue
from the south side of the building
however they function less like a
traditional police force and more like a
private security company
if like maineville and zemo your family
happens to be the one that gets blown up
in their latest attempt at saving the
world you might even consider them
terrorists what would you call a group
of us-based
enhanced individuals who routinely
ignore
sovereign borders and inflict their will
wherever they choose and who frankly
seem
unconcerned about what they leave behind
the socobia accords then are the
westphalian world dealing with
post-westphalian realities
the debate over the accords is grounded
in two competing views of how the
international arena works realism
and liberalism realism argues that
states are self-interested power-seeking
rational actors who seek to maximize
their security and chances of survival
liberalism stresses interdependence
among states multinational corporations
and international institutions
arguing that these various actors can
and should work together for the benefit
of all
the sokovia accords fit this liberalist
paradigm to a t
under the new rules set out in the
accords government actors
i.e the un will work together with
non-governmental forces
in this case the avengers for the
presumed common good
this means more rules and greater
oversight for the avengers who will no
longer be able to gallivant around the
globe fighting whenever and wherever
they please
compromise reassurance that's how the
world works
tony stark buys into the accord's
liberalist framework but still manages
to do plenty of gallivanting
you seriously think i'm gonna listen to
you after that fiasco and leipzig
he argues that cooperation with
sovereign governments even to the point
of accepting the imposed limitations
is crucial for stark respect for the
interdependent world order is part of
what separates the avengers
from the terrorist groups they fight we
need to be put in check
whatever form that takes i'm game if we
can't accept limitations we're
boundary-less we know better
than the bad guys steve rogers on the
other hand is a
realist he's focused on security and his
own agenda first and foremost
and argues against the sokovia courts on
the grounds that they will make the
avengers less able to respond to
critical situations
thereby putting the world in danger if
we call tony
he won't believe us even if he did who
knows if the accords will let him help
we're on our own while the realist
position allows for cooperation that
will increase the likelihood of the
world's survival
captain america is simply unconvinced
that this cooperation will improve
security for anyone
steve argues that the shifting agendas
of those who uphold the accords
could lead to compromised security down
the line this is the united nations
we're talking about it's not
the world security council it's not
shield it's not hydra no but it's run by
people with agendas and agendas change
the film asked some pretty heavy
questions that may as well be directed
at a modern superpower
is unfettered power inherently dangerous
do
rules only tie up crucial fighting
forces in dangerous amounts of red tape
instead of providing some black and
white answer for an insanely complex
question
the film offers us some ambiguity while
one may criticize captain america for
his unilateral approach to solving
things
let's not tell you anything else that
you're wrong you think you're right
it makes you dangerous you could eagerly
say the same of tony stark as he tries
to enforce the sokovia accords leading
to plenty of collateral damage along the
way
while exploring these international
frameworks the film also explores how
personal ethics can complicate these
concepts
when a terrorist blows up the u.n
killing black panther's father
he goes on the hunt for presumed culprit
bucky barnes the attack on the u.n
creates a rift between those avengers
who want the government to take in bucky
and those who believe captain america is
right to attempt his own rescue
for this conflict the film asks us to
consider whether it's better to act
based on a preconceived set of moral
obligations
like the captain's obligation to bucky
or with consideration for the greater
good
like stark and his compatriots tony
stark and his gang embody a branch of
philosophy known as utilitarianism
which holds that actions should be
judged based on their overall
consequences
rather than on their adherence to
abstract ideals tony stark believes that
oversight will reduce the amount of
collateral damage caused by their
activities
and that this is reason enough to
support the sokovia courts
above and beyond his belief in the
usefulness of a liberalist world order
tony stark supports the accords because
they align with his own utilitarian
conception of morality
these two ideas are different though not
necessarily contradictory
while he knows that the new rules will
inconvenience him and his team he's
convinced that they will improve the lot
of humanity as a whole
it's not about his personal convictions
it's about the greater good
captain rogers i know you believe what
you're doing is right
but for the collective good you must
surrender now
captain america on the other hand flirts
with an ethical position known as
deontology
deontology judges the morality of an
action itself without consideration for
the effects that said action might have
again not contradictory to his realist
beliefs but different nonetheless
from a deontological perspective certain
actions can never be justified no matter
how much they might promote some greater
good
like killing an innocent person even if
it could save millions more
while steve rogers isn't a perfect
deontologist in the sense of og
deontologist emmanuel kant he acts
according to personal laws rather than
universal ones
he bases his actions around a set of
moral duties
cap believes that his moral duty to save
his friend bucky barnes
trumps whatever greater good might be
served by his death or imprisonment no
matter how many cops bucky happens to
beat the piss out of
in the film's closing minutes we learned
that all the carnage betrayal
and heartbreak we've followed for the
last two hours is the secret plan of
former sokovian special operative
zemo whose loved ones were more
collateral damage of the avengers
zemora feels that it was his plan all
along to tear the avengers apart by
showing tony stark footage of bucky
barnes murdering his parents
an empire toppled by its enemies can
rise again
but one which crumbles from within
[Music]
that's dead forever
and here i think the film suggests a
failing of all these philosophical
systems
no matter how right participants in
these systems believe they are
there will always be somebody who gets
the shaft tony stark is confronted by
the mother of one of the many eggs he
had to crack in order to make a
superhero omelet
who's going to avenge my son stark
he's dead and i blame you
she is essentially in the same camp as
zemo whether you're operating for the
greater good
your personal ethics at the behest of
your own country or an international
agreement
there's always a zemo that loses out and
that's the problem with the force as
powerful as the avengers
as vision says our very strength invites
challenge challenge incites conflict
and conflict
breeds catastrophe someone is always
going to get shafted by these
philosophical systems
but when the team doing the shafting has
the collective force of a nuclear
superpower
the forces that challenge them will
invite equally destructive force
and that can turn out pretty poorly for
the world so
what do you think are the avengers right
to agree to the accords should captain
america give up his own code for the
greater good
or are there just no right answers let
us know what you think in the comments
and thanks for watching
peace want to make like steve and tony
and lead your own team of marvel
characters into battle
download marvel puzzle quest today for
free to live out your comic book
fantasies
marvel puzzle quest is a match 3 puzzle
rpg featuring characters from across the
marvel universe
create your own dream team of heroes and
villains to take part in awesome single
player action
as well as weekly tournaments and events
all written by bonafide marvel writers
you can even form alliances with your
friends to rank up in the leaderboards
and earn
cool rewards the game's available now on
your mobile device and steam
oh and marvel puzzle quest is getting
updated constantly with new characters
this month they're adding craven the
hunter and ghost rider specifically
robbie reyes is ghostwriter who you
might remember from agents of shield
and word on the street is that they're
putting together some exciting stuff for
the upcoming release of the black
panther movie so stay tuned for that
to top it all off the team behind marvel
puzzle quest is offering wisecrack fans
a free character to add to your team
just go to d3go.com wisecrack or click
the link in the description to add sam
wilson you know falcon
to your team for free thanks to marvel
puzzle quest for sponsoring this video
be sure to subscribe and ring that bell
so you won't miss all the great stuff
we've got coming
that's all for now thanks for watching
y'all peace